so today is something I've never done
before I'm going to give a lecture
through my computer and the telephone to
the National Academy of Sciences in
United States the reason I'm doing this
is because people have seen our periodic
videos they're having a conference in
the United States about how to take
chemistry to the public they think our
project is really interesting and they
want to know how we do it so I'm here
with Brady I'm going to give a talk and
then the two of us are going to answer
questions via the telephone let's see if
it works
so I'm now dialing in on the computer
your conference will begin very shortly
please continue to hold the line in the
rehearsal I didn't I got on the computer
but I didn't know the phone number so
eventually I had to type a message
saying help and show it on my screen and
they called me
good morning everybody can you see my
screen
my name is Barton Polyakov and I'm here
in my office with my video journalist
collaborator Brady Haran who will be
available to answer questions later
and at the moment is videoing what's
happening at my end so if it's exciting
you may see it on YouTube later today or
tomorrow and these are the other members
of our team whose wishes are with you
but not in my office because you
wouldn't understand anything if they did
all spoke at once as Sharon said in the
introduction my interests in research is
in green chemistry cleaner approaches
for making chemicals and materials and
my particular area of interest is
cleaner solvents and through this I have
done a lot of research in the area of
supercritical fluids highly compressed
carbon dioxide highly compressed steam
which can be used as solvents for
reactions and as a result of this
demonstrations of supercritical fluids
were recorded by Brady Haran on his
YouTube channel that he began for the
University called test-tube here and
this is me demonstrating supercritical
fluids this video has now been watched
by nearly 50,000 people and as a result
of this Brady and I really got on well
together and Brady had the idea that we
should make a periodic table of videos
this is a website where every element
has its own video I told him he was
completely mad and what would we say
about elements like the ones down here
which only a few atoms have been made or
never been made at all and after some
discussion he persuaded me it would be a
good idea if you click on one of these
videos as buttons as you saw in the
video you get a short clip hosted on
YouTube this is our first hydrogen video
to one so the main facts were that we
began filming on June the 9th 2008 and
we recorded the first 36 elements or my
part of the first 36 elements in two
hours in my office and the website was
completed on the 17th of July just under
six weeks but so the current state is or
rather it was on we've had at least 11
million hits and this number is now
really not very clear because how do you
count a class of schoolchildren that
have all watched at once and the number
of hits on YouTube for hydrogen is now
over 280 1000 and these are some of the
countries that it has been watched in
I've highlighted obviously the United
Kingdom where Nottingham is I hope you
will realize Nottingham is in the UK and
then I've highlighted Malaysia and China
where my University has campuses and
also Ethiopia where we have a very
strong collaboration and we've had lots
of comments on YouTube the first one
here awesome vids wish I'd found them
before I did my science GCSE exam GCS is
six school and high school exam for 16
year olds of course you can't tell
whether this is from a 16 year old or
from somebody in their 40s who is
bewailing his misspent youth then I love
your videos just watching these videos
I've learnt more than the full term at
college and videos like these is what
makes me interested in school and better
improving myself thank you then there
are more stayed messages this one is
from Radley College which is a high
school in Abingdon which is near Oxford
the periodic table of videos that have
now become an essential opening to any
lesson with the chemistry sets that I
teach set means class not a sort of set
of test tubes and then thanks again for
developing such a wonderful teaching aid
that
has already inspired great interest in
chemistry Brady who's quite an internet
freak managed to download all the
comments to all our videos about two
weeks ago and analyzed the words and
these are the top hundred words in
frequency so you can see there's
chemistry and elements and love which is
quite encouraging then perhaps more
strangely professor and hare you have
seen me all on the video which but
they're things like uranium and so on so
it's quite as of encouraging and warm
thing and also things like awesome cool
which and and interesting which are not
words that are normally associated with
chemistry sort of nasty toxic and so on
don't appear at all here are some of the
early press cuttings BBC turkish service
Russian business magazine this is
chemical engineering news I can't
remember this one the mail online the
Daily Mail is a sort of middle
right-wing newspaper in the UK this
comes from an Israeli business magazine
it took me long time to have this
translated but it's the the key line in
here says he looks as if he went to the
barber and said give me an Einstein and
make it look wild for all his celebrated
work as a research chemist and
university professor Martin Polyakov
didn't become a celebrity till he got on
the Internet
as the emcee of an online version of the
periodic table of elements illustrated
with experiments performed by his
colleagues at the University of
Nottingham aufs encyclopedic knowledge
of what happens in the test tube has
made him a sensation on YouTube so what
we have done is as well as doing videos
about the elements updating them we've
had videos gold silver and bronze if any
of you are not chemist bronze is not an
element which was for the Olympic Games
when the Large Hadron Collider leaked
helium and closed-down we made
to explain why when the Nobel Prize in
2008 we had nearly 40,000 hits in one
week describing what the prize was about
this was more than the official Nobel
Prize video got for that week and then
we did candles at Halloween which was
extremely successful and a whole series
of other one nice sunny weather in
Stockholm I don't know what to think
about this am I'm getting the feeling
that I can't might be covered in snow it
may take a while to to find a car so
we're in Addis Ababa University in the
science faculty Alec kilo and it's 23
degrees it's nice and pleasant we have
now done a whole series of road trips
this is a road trip I made to damn start
where they discovered elements and I'm
in the control room where element 111
was discovered we had put subtitles on
the videos here subtitles in English
and - in Spanish we have got over a
hundred videos that have been subtitled
in Portuguese we now have some in
Turkish even in Indonesian brady went on
holiday to new york and as a side trip
went to visit a school in Pittsford in
upstate New York Barker Road middle
school where the teacher Bob Roundtree
had emailed me and I'm actually wearing
the tie that he gave me sent me through
the internet but not through the
internet that sent me by post and so
Brady videoed the children at the school
watching a video that I'd made he also
videoed the children asking me questions
this young girl is got a model and is
asking me whether she should call the
element aluminum or aluminium is it
aluminum or aluminium because I wouldn't
know what to call my album any of
and then I was videoed answering these
questions and both of these in fact now
we had two videos that were put out with
me answering the school kids questions
hi it's a great model and you should
call it aluminium we have collaborated
with the Broadway cinema which is the
leading private independent cinema in
our town and in November 2008 they
showed the video on the small screens
the screens that people watch in the
fray and when they're queueing for
tickets and things like that and then in
May last year we did a live performance
in the cinema think about this doing
chemical demonstrations in a carpeted
room with no chemical facilities and
here's Sam Tang demonstrating dry ice on
the stage at the Broadway cinema and
here's me watching a video of myself
it's pretty unnerving to see your head
of ten feet high on the screen and it
was really quite successful and we're
going to do a similar performance at the
European Science Festival yourself in
Turin in July we've also been in
exhibitions this is the university's
Pavilion at the Shanghai Expo running at
the moment and here you can see somebody
and this is a real picture it's not
posed this is not a model watching the
periodic videos in China so here is our
team you can see this is Brady Sam tang
Steve little who's an expert in
lanthanide elements and uranium Pete
license who does most of the
demonstrations and you saw on the video
Debbie Kay's who has gone on screen to
say that she loves boron and Neil Barnes
who is our lung suffering technician
Neil rarely says anything on-screen but
it has become a real cult figure on the
internet and there's me with my periodic
table umbrella we have
had a display put in the catalyst
discovery center in witness which is
northeast of England one of the very few
museums in England devoted to chemistry
here is their display a bit bigger here
and it's really quite popular I've met
people who've said my children saw your
display in the museum and so again we're
using a different way of distributing
this and I've had a mad idea which I
perhaps would like to put to the
audience
perhaps somebody can help me is that I
think that these videos would be great
for in-flight entertainment on a DVD on
the aeroplane imagine their people
sitting there with their little screens
feeling really bored and so they can
watch clips which are quite short the
longest one is ten minutes and the
others are rather shorter and they're
the sort of thing that they can nudge
their neighbor and say have you seen
this one and so on so I think this is a
real captive audience to which the
message of chemistry can be taken and
the final thing I'd like to end up with
a quote from this Youtube subscriber
here who is a single mother who wrote my
11 year old science geeks and adores
your videos when I picked him up from
school this afternoon I had the pleasure
of telling him breaking news in the
world of chemistry he immediately burst
out loudly and excited there's a new
periodic video thanks to y'all he was
mercifully quick and uncomplaining about
his homework tonight he's often
otherwise sigh so he could get to watch
the new videos before time for church
and so at this point I'd say that I've
enjoyed presenting to you please asked
lots of questions